dictature économique on pourrait se
demander si on est dedans on pas quand
j'entends certains injonction à la
croissance permanente en fait moi ça
m'intéresse pas la croissance parce que
on ne sait même pas ce qu'on mesure en
fait personne ne sait ce qu'il ya
derrière je vais vous donner un exemple
qui pour moi était à ses parents ce qui
est un progrès c'est d'équiper les
ménages de machines à laver manger à
voir ça et ne plus faire son lavage à la
main et bassa émancipe notamment les
femmes de tâches qui sont ardues qui
sont compliqués et qui empêchent
notamment de s'éduquer
qu'est-ce qu'on a besoin c'est que tout
le monde ait un lave linge c'est pas que
tout le monde change son influence pour
les trois ans or aujourd'hui la
croissance s'est changé son lave-linge
pour les trois ans c'est un acquis il on
a tous un lave-linge pas tous mais
globalement le en france on équipés de
la plage la moitié des bd des habitants
du monde ne le sont pas eux ils ont
besoin d'avoir accès à ces la blanche
maison pas besoin et ce qu'on leur vend
c'est pas ça c'est d'avoir accès à un
lave-linge qu'on va changer tous les
trois ans où satan ou peu importe et ça
ça le problème c'est que l'on veut
absolument rentrer dedans quand on a cet
impératif de l'oac de la croissance
c'est un impératif à l'obsolescence
d'une certaine manière qu'est j'actionne
un autre élément sur les éléments
technologiques en fait aujourd'hui les
pays qui se dit se développer il va en
fait ils ont développé tellement de
choses qui doivent maintenir des
infrastructures et ça c'est important et
on voit ça se casse la gueule aux états
unis parce qu'ils sont plus en capacité
de maintenir ses infrastructures et en
fait nous de voix par notre niveau parce
que l'on a développé déjà investir des
budgets colossaux dont le maintien de ce
qui est existant alors investir encore
des dizaines de milliards et des
centaines de milliards pour des progrès
techniques technologiques c'est bien
beau mais en fait ça va être au
détriment de beaucoup c'est vrai qu'on
va assurer un développement de
d'ailleurs je ne sais pas trop quoi pour
quelques-uns au détriment de l'ensemble
qui va devoir nécessairement réduire son
niveau de vie puisque c'est une variable
qui est qui est assez parlante
c'est ça les éléments que qui pour moi
sont apposées aux débats c'est qu'est ce
qu'est ce que l'on souhaite avoir dans
l'avenir
[Musique]